while we were talking about the adaptive immune system, we already
we saw there are several actors.
First we have the humorous reaction.
This is a reaction to things that fly
around body fluids, but not only
things that have penetrated the body. Then we have
cellular immune response.
And then the humorous answer - and we are talking
for a specific immune response - that is, where the B cells,
B-lymphocytes are the most active.
And basically what they do is, we have a cell here
It has a specific antibody specific for only
this B cell, not all B cells.
This is one of the billions of B cells,
which incidentally has the right key - or
perhaps the proper lock for the key it represents
the attacking pathogen - the pathogen which,
will connect to this B cell.
It may be a virus, it may be a bacterium.
And then the cell will activate and we'll talk
in this video that activation
does not always happen.
In fact, it's usually not only the result,
but so far we have said that it is activated, this is remembered
of B cells that are actually multiple versions of
this original cage - say, let's have a lot
versions of this - because it usually recognizes this virus.
So if we meet this virus again in the future, these multitudes
versions, these multiple memory cells will be available,
to participate in this interaction.
This interaction is more likely to happen in
future because we will have more than that
type B cell.
And then we have effector cells.
And these are actually ... Both are B cells.
This cell, once activated, propagates,
continues to divide and clone itself.
Memory cells just sit around waiting to be activated
in the future.
I only paint one of these membrane-associated antibodies,
but we actually have about 10,000 of them.
I mean, I could draw many of them.
I do not have to paint only one.
Memory cells just walk around in the future,
but now we have more of them.
So in the future, if we come across this virus again,
this interaction will happen faster and so
they will be activated faster.
And then effector B cells
are turned into antibody factories.
This antibody goes in and says, let me just produce ...
I'm activated.
Let me produce many, many more versions
from exactly that antibody.
So she ejects them.
I drew it a little wrong.
This antibody, this can then be sent
exclude or mark antigens - and not any antigens -
exactly that antigen here.
We also saw that the other thing that the cage is doing is,
that it becomes an antigen displaying a cell.